[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL MATTHEWS: Hello,
and welcome
to this OAuth2 session.
I'm Paul Matthews.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the AdWords API,
and this is Marc.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: Hi my name
is Marc Wandschneider, and I'm
a developer advocate
here at Google.
And I also work on
the AdWords API.
PAUL MATTHEWS: So today we're
going to talk to you about
authorization, and in
particular, OAuth2.
For the moment, changes are
coming for the authentication
of your applications.
At the moment, many of your apps
are using ClientLogin.
This is a sort of flow for how
ClientLogin is authenticating
with a service.
So your app talks to the
authentication service, blah,
blah, blah.
Your app gets an access token,
or an AuthToken, in this case.
Your app talks to the Product
API servers and passes in
Developer key and access token,
and your app has to
periodically re-authenticate
with the servers.
So this, as I said, is
called ClientLogin.
So how will it work
in the new world?
In the OAuth2 world, your app
will talk to the application
servers, wah, wah, wah.
Your app gets an access token.
Sound familiar?
Your app talks to the Product
API servers and passes in the
Developer Key and
access token.
And your app has to periodically
re-authenticate.
So this new way of doing
it is OAuth2.
Don't panic!
This shouldn't be a big deal
for you, and it will
drastically improve security of
your applications and data.
So what's wrong with
ClientLogin?
Why do we want to move
away from it?
What's the investment
worth for you?
At the moment, ClientLogin works
on a process of username
and passwords for products
being shared around.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: And you
actually have to put
them in your code.
So your code base is sitting
there with your username and
password stuck in it,
which is not ideal.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Exactly.
And it's quite easy to
accidentally get your code
leaked out to the world.
And if that happens, then
you're sending private
credentials out there, which is
a very bad security crisis.
So once you authenticate
with our servers, our
authentication servers, at the
moment, your access token,
your AuthToken, lasts for
around two weeks.
There's no way to revoke this
token, or no easy way to
revoke this token at present.
And the main thing, the real
drive behind this, is that
ClientLogin is being sunset by
2015, and it might be sooner.
It's actually been
in deprecated
mode since last year.
So it's really time to start
thinking about changing over
to pastures new.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: Definitely
being discouraged.
PAUL MATTHEWS: So why OAuth2?
Well, OAuth2 primarily,
and this is the
driver, is more secure.
It doesn't expose usernames and
passwords, and you only
exchange OAuth tokens.
You get more specific
access control.
So rather than relying on any
person with your credentials
access to all of your data, you
can rein in and allow them
access to particular portions
of your data.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER:
Or even APIs.
I can say like with a particular
set of OAuth
tokens, this one can only accept
access to Mapping API.
This this one can only access
certain geolocation APIs, and
everything.
You can actually severely
restrict the scope of the
individual access credentials
being issued.
So again, if they're
compromised, the amount of
damage that can be
done is limited.
PAUL MATTHEWS: So, as he was
alluding to, it drastically
reduces the impact if a
token is compromised.
There's no CAPTCHA challenges
with OAuth2, which is really
good for any of you that might
want to put this system into
an automatic process,
like a Chrome job or
something like that.
Where CAPTCHA would just
halt the whole
process and stop it dead.
And we've learned a lot from the
OAuth1.0 days, and really
the standard has grown up a
lot, and OAuth2 is a much
better revision.
So what are the key
steps to OAuth2?
You start off by registering
an OAuth application.
This is very simple, and we'll
go through that shortly.
You authenticate to
get an auth code.
So that's where the
authentication servers.
You exchange your auth code
for an access token and
refresh token.
More on that later.
And you call the Product API
with the access token.
And finally you handle
token expiration.
So you'll see a lot of this
happens before you even get
into calling the APIs
you're used to.
So step one, registering
the application.
You go to
code.google.com/apis/console
and you create a new project.
This is how you create
a new project.
So you just hit the Create
project button.
It's nice and easy.
And it'll take you through
to this screen.
And it'll actually take you
through to the Overview
screen, where you can click on
API access and create a new
OAuth2 Client ID in secret.
Where you'll be prompted
with this box.
There's no saying that we don't
show you every in-depth
detail of this.
So this box will allow you to
put in your product name, and
that's really the crucial
part of this.
You can put in a product logo
if you have one, and maybe a
home page URL for additional
information.
The next step, you choose the
application type, the workflow
type, the OAuth2 type.
More on that later.
But in this particular example,
we're selecting the
web application, the web flow
layout, and we're filling in
other additional details
that might be needed to
achieve that flow.
Finally, there's a redirect
URL at the bottom.
And we click create client ID.
And it'll produce something
like this.
You'll see this nice
little box.
It'll explain it to you, give
you the Client ID, Email
address, Client secret, Redirect
URL, and JavaScript,
all that information that you
have to deal with for the
OAuth2 login.
And conveniently, there's a
download to JSON format, so
you can just pick this all out
as a file, and drop this into
most Google applications or
Google libraries, and it
should read from that.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: So I'm going
to go here and just sort
of, I guess, slightly more
technical details about how
all this works and everything.
I'm going to go back one slide
here, and mention here that
you can download--
you'll see here on the right--
you can download these
credentials and everything.
You can actually just copy
them from this page.
But typically, what we'll do
is we'll download the JSON,
keep that in a JSON file.
And again, that's not perfect.
But you can't have the perfect
security model.
And again, having these
credentials stored in your
source tree is far safer than
having your username and
password, because if they get
compromised, you can easily
just revoke them with the DELETE
button you see right
here, and then ask for a
new set of credentials.
So this picture here is
from our Google OAuth
documentation page.
So you can go on to the internet
and view it later.
We will show you the link for
that at the end of this
presentation.
But the basic flow is your
application here is going to
begin the authentication
process.
And it's going to ask Google
to begin the authentication
process and start giving me some
tokens and everything.
This is going to redirect my
application to some sort of
Google authentication page,
or pop up, or some sort of
scheme, depending on what type
of application I have.
And I'll talk about that
in just a second.
Once Google has decided to
authenticate me, and has
verified that the user and
password are all kosher and
everything, they will send back
a code to my application,
or my web app, or something.
My application then, with that
code in hand, recalls Google
again, exchanges those for a
token response, which has a
couple of different things
in it, which we can
use to call the APIs.
All right so, before we scare
everybody with all the
technical details, if you're
using Google Client Libraries,
they're almost all already up
to date in all the languages
for all of this authentication
and all of
these different methods.
So you should be able to just
change your methods to
OAuth2.0, and have
everything work.
You just need to plug in the
secret and the tokens that you
got from the API console
earlier on.
For those few libraries that are
possibly out of date right
now, or don't handle everything
quite perfectly,
you should expect those to be
migrated over and fully
supported in the very near
future, as we're moving
everything away from
ClientLogin and
towards this OAuth2.0.
So if you're not using a client
library and you're
coding this stuff by hand, let's
go into the details a
little bit more of
how you do that.
You send a request to the Google
Authorization Server
with what you want to access.
This is what we said earlier
was the scope.
So for example, if I'm writing
an app that uses the AdWords
API, I'll say I want to
authenticate this application
against this URL, which
is the AdWords.
I also pass in the client ID and
the client secret, which
we got from the API console
in that JSON on file.
Now we have to actually go
and authenticate it.
In most of the flows, this will
involve actually Google
popping up a login dialog or
validating that the user wants
to grant your application access
to the APIs on their
behalf, and sort of tell
Google they're
doing things with it.
Once you've given that, the
Google servers return a code
back to your application that
your application can, in the
final step, exchange for
an accessToken and a
refreshToken.
So how do we use these tokens
that are returned?
The accessToken is the
token that I pass
into the API calls.
It is passed in actually
as a header.
An HTTP header called
authorization, and you say
OAuth, and you pass in this
token that you got back.
This expires after
about an hour.
I've seen maybe a few minutes
give or take on this.
But roughly after an hour, this
token will stop working.
And actually when you first
get these tokens back, you
actually get a timeout value
with that JSON response.
PAUL MATTHEWS: It's probably
worth saying, that's usually
the one that you
want to go on.
You don't necessarily need to
make the request to confirm
that it's still valid.
You just go by the time out.
Then after the time out, you
would just refresh your token.
You wouldn't bother waiting
until it definitely expired.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: Right.
And then you do have
this refreshToken.
And the refreshToken is how
you actually get another
accessToken when your
accessTokens do time out.
So the nice thing about these is
I don't need to pop up the
authentication dialog again.
The user doesn't have to come
back and enter the username or
password, or authorize my app,
or click any buttons.
I just say all right, that
old token has expired.
Please give me a new accessToken
with this
refreshToken, and I'll
get a new one.
So you should probably store
that when you first get it, so
that when your accessToken
does expire, you'll
be given a new one.
You'll be able to get a new
accessToken from that
refreshToken.
So let's talk a little
bit about the
various different flows.
The nice thing about OAuth2.0
on the big improvements it
offers over OAuth1.0, are the
ways in which it supports the
various different apps.
Whether they be web
applications, mobile
applications on your Android
or other type of phone, or
even server side applications.
There are some flows-- that we
won't get time to talk about
today-- but they're for true
server side scenarios.
You can even skip some of the
parts of this process if you
can sort of pre-verify the
security and sort of isolated
nature of your application.
But the key ones here,
definitely we'll start with
the web flow.
Which is I'm running a web
application, the user,
somebody browses in to my
application, that application
now needs to use a Google API.
So it will redirect to Google
for authentication.
Once Google has verified I am
who I say I am, and is happy
with me, they redirect back to
my application with a little
code that my application can
then exchange for those two
tokens, and go ahead and start
calling the API as it wishes.
Another way that this can be
done is what's called the
installed outflow.
And for sure, the most common
use of this will be in mobile
applications on iOS
or an Android.
The user starts using
my application.
I want access to an API.
I need to authenticate.
I'll pop up a web view control
with the Google authentication
page on it.
The user authenticates.
And then when Google is happy
with that authentication,
there's this funny problem where
we've got to figure out
how do we get that code back
to the application.
And amazingly enough, in the
OAuth2.0 world, the way this
is done is you set the title
of the web view.
You set the title of the
next page that the
OAuth server is showing.
And then the installed
application here will actually
scrape that web view control,
or whatever it is, grab the
title, and then exchange that
for an accessToken and
refreshToken.
So that's how that does.
And you can totally see this
being done in your installed
applications.
Now it's worth noting that that
installed application
flow, popping up a web view,
does sort of have some
security implications and some
security concerns with it.
Theoretically, anybody can
pop-up an HTML page that sort
of looks like a Google login
screen, or some sort of other
login screen.
And we might want to worry
about that a little bit.
So there are a couple of options
for us to do it better
on, in particular here, I'll
talk about iOS and Android.
On iOS, my application can
actually register a custom URL
Handler to receive the
code from Google.
And then also, Google Apps,
whether I'm using Google+ or
something else on my iOS device,
it will have a custom
URL Handler.
And I can actually say, go
ahead and call that to
authenticate my application.
Once Google has verified that
my application is properly
authenticated, it'll actually
call that custom URL Handler
that I've registered Because I
set that as the redirect URL
in the API console.
And that will actually just
switch right back to my
application with that code that
I need to exchange for
the two tokens.
So that's actually a way.
It is a little funny in iOS.
You'll see the app quickly
switch to Google.
And then, if I've already
authenticated, it'll just
actually switch right
back to my app.
Otherwise, I'll enter my
username, password, and then
it'll switch back to my app.
It works really well.
And again, it's definitely
more secure than
a web page or something.
The great part is that actually,
for Android users,
there are built in authorization
managers to do
all of this for you,
and handle OAuth.
And indeed, if you're trying
to authenticate against the
sort of priming account on your
Android device, it'll
just seamlessly go
through the whole
authentication process for you.
So that is definitely the most
secure way to do that on those
two mobile platforms.
For web applications, also a lot
of people are starting to
move away from this switch
to a full Google page,
authenticate, and then switch
back to my application.
And there's this new methodology
being done using
HTML5's Window postMessage.
Where actually I create an
iFrame with the Google
authentication system in it.
I post messages to it.
It decides whether it needs
to do a pop-up, and get my
username, password,
and everything.
And then my web application
and the iFrame communicate
with each other.
Get the code back.
Exchange those for tokens
and everything.
So this is a new way
that's being done.
You're seeing this a lot right
now with Google+, and I think
you'll see this expand to a
lot more services here at
Google and everything.
So it's definitely something
you can explore.
Especially if you're really
working with HTML5 and a lot
of the new stuff.
And back to Paul.
PAUL MATTHEWS: So OAuth2
best practices.
To start off, although we give
you a refreshToken and an
accessToken, we really expect
you to use the accessToken as
much as possible.
So yes, in theory, you could
refresh your accessToken on
every call to the API, but
firstly, you making pointless
additional calls to our API.
That's going to be a performance
hit to you.
And secondly, it's going to
increase our load and slow
down the whole process, our end
as well, meaning a lower
quality of service
for yourselves.
So we really expect you to honor
the timeout value of any
returned token.
Secondly, you must make
sure you store the
refreshToken for reuse.
If you don't store the
refreshToken, what you end up
with is always having to us
for user interaction.
And obviously, that's just
about acceptable on some
applications, but if you're
talking about any services or
anything like that, that you
don't want a user involved in,
then that's going to be
a serious problem.
And secondly, a user is going to
become rather agitated with
your application if you're
having to give consent on
every request.
And also obviously, it reduces
the number of round trips to
the service.
So how to handle
expired tokens.
What do I need to handle
expired tokens?
Basically, your application--
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: Your
application today, when you're
using ClientLogin, has
to already have
logic to handle timeouts.
Like you need to be able to
handle the case where Google
servers come back and
say your client auth
token has already expired.
So you already need to have
logic today to say my token
has expired.
Pause this call, go ahead and
reauthenticate, and then go
back and resume that call.
So you've probably already
got logic for this.
Or you should have logic to
handle this sort of token
timeout thing.
So theoretically, switching to
OAuth, with the timeout being
every hour, shouldn't
be a big deal.
If you haven't written that code
yet, you're definitely
going to need to now [INAUDIBLE]
timeouts.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Additionally,
on top of that, if you are
writing the code to handle the
handshake that the client
consent you don't want to
write that code and
then ship it out.
This consent step could,
in theory, come
back and hit you again.
So the point is that you want
to leave that in your code,
even if it's a service
application-- like a Chrome
job or something--
you still want to leave that in
your code, and then just to
be able to handle
that experience.
So in summary, change
is coming.
It shouldn't be a big deal, and
it shouldn't be too much
coding or hard work on your
end to handle it.
It'll actually improve the
application security and thus
reduce liability and worry
for system administrators
everywhere.
Any client library users of
Google client libraries should
be able to switch over
now, or pretty soon.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER:
Change is coming.
I'm immediately like,
winter is coming.
PAUL MATTHEWS: So this would be
time for a Q&A had we got
any people on the Hang Out,
but unfortunately no one
showed up today.
So we're going to
skip past this.
So on to some links for you.
The main one here is the
developers.googl
e.com/accounts/docs/OAuth2.
This will give you the vast
majority of OAuth2 information
you'll need.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: If you
don't remember that, just
Google search Google
APIs OAuth.
It's the first organic
result, absolutely.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Secondly, if you
find yourself needing to
register your account, you
need to look at the
code.google.com/apis/console.
So that'll be where you register
your account, as I
showed you previously.
So, thank you for watching
this OAuth2 session.
I've been Paul Matthews.
MARC WANDSCHNEIDER: You still
are Paul Matthews.
And I remain Marc Wandschneider,
and it's been a
lot of fun, and we
hope you learned
something from it today.
PAUL MATTHEWS: Thank
you all so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]